hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña andrés zarautz él es candidato
a la presidencia de ecuador por el
frente unión por la esperanza formación
de la que hace parte también el ex
presidente ecuatoriano rafael correa él
es político y también economista fue
director del banco central de ecuador
además de haber ocupado cargos en la
administración pública durante los
mandatos de correa quien iba a ser
precisamente su compañero de fórmula
como vicepresidente señora muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24
muchísimas gracias a santiago por la
invitación estamos aquí contentos de
estar y obviamente también contentos de
participar en este proceso electoral
contestó nosotros también de tenerlo en
nuestra pantalla señor araus luego de la
sentencia judicial no en que
imposibilitó a rafael correa a
participar en las elecciones del 7 de
febrero de 2021 como su compañero de
fórmula recordemos que la justicia de
ecuador ratificó la condena al ex
mandatario por presunta corrupción y lo
inhabilitó para presentarse como
candidato a la vicepresidencia del país
y también ejercer cargos públicos su
fuerza política sin embargo ya eligió al
periodista carlos rabascal como
candidato a la vicepresidencia de
reemplazo de rafael correa en qué
situación se encuentra la inscripción se
ha formalizado ya ante la entidad
electoral
si mira rafael correa fue primero
elegido en las primarias de centro
democrático listas 1 que es el partido
por el cual estamos participando dentro
de la alianza y luego que ganó las
primarias se decidió por parte de la
justicia ecuatoriana emitir una
sentencia aceleradísima que demoró 16
días a penas y con ello se inhabilitó a
rafael correa luego que ya había ganado
las primarias es por esta razón que a
pesar de que ya tenemos a carlos abascal
como nuestra compañera definida de
fórmula primero teníamos que hacer la
solicitud de inscripción de rafael
correa porque él ganó las primarias para
que luego lo podamos reemplazar
abramos el debido proceso ante nuestro
consejo nacional electoral ahora este
cambio de candidato a vicepresidente
generó siete repercusiones no hay
reacciones hay algunos juristas que
señalan que no sería posible la
inscripción del binomio porque en las
elecciones primarias resultó electo
correa existe la posibilidad de una
eventual descalificación del nuevo
binomio araus rabascal a nivel jurídico
mover lamentar yo no hay ningún riesgo
de que eso ocurra está establecido
perfectamente en la ley que si un
candidato tiene alguna inhabilidad pues
será reemplazado por otro que no
necesariamente haya tenido que
participar en las primarias así que no
nos preocupa desde el ámbito jurídico
sin embargo hemos estado viviendo un
régimen de facto que ha ido cambiando la
interpretación de las leyes con
objetivos políticos y la preocupación
nuestra es más política de que viéndose
en desventaja frente a nuestra irrupción
en el escenario electoral liderando las
encuestas quieran evitar nuestra
participación por esa razón hemos pedido
a las naciones unidas al año europea a
los latinoamericanos que observen de
cerca lo que está ocurriendo en el
ecuador para que no hayan amenazas a la
democracia como decía al comienzo de la
entrevista recientemente la justicia
ecuatoriana emitió una orden de
localización y de captura contra el ex
presidente de rafael correa que vive en
bélgica recordemos desde el año 2017
imagino que usted se habrá comunicado
cómo reaccionó el exmandatario ante esto
mira obviamente hay un momento de
indignación porque así han sido todo
tres solicitudes que el gobierno del
ecuador ha planteado de captura
internacional entre line interpol y la
interpol las han negado todas porque no
se respeta el debido proceso en los
procesos judiciales en contra de rafael
correa y estamos seguros que en este
caso tampoco se respetará esta solicitud
de captura internacional puesto que
estamos viendo una interferencia expresa
del gobierno en la función judicial como
objetivos de impedir su participación
política y con el objetivo de que los
ecuatorianos puedan elegir a quien
quieren elegir en todo caso no deja de
ser indignante dolorosa esta decisión
pero estamos confiados de que cuando
recuperemos la patria recuperemos
también la institucionalidad democrática
o una verdadera independencia judicial
ahora hay una comparación que muchísimo
se realiza seguro se lo han preguntado
muchas veces si ese es el caso le pidió
disculpas por tener que responderlo
nuevamente pero es que la fórmula suya y
del ex presidente rafael correa
aspirando a la vice president
podría compararse con el caso de alberto
fernández y de cristina fernández en las
elecciones de 2019 en argentina porque
cuando todos apostaban a que la ex
presidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner iba a ser la candidata
presidencial sorprendió a todos con su
candidatura a vicepresidenta en una
estrategia que finalmente le dio buenos
resultados porque vencieron a mauricio
macri se inspiraron por decirlo de
alguna manera en la experiencia de
argentina
mira yo entiendo que la comparación es
inevitable sin embargo en el caso de
nuestro viene por aristas diferentes
nosotros hemos tratado de más bien
sobrevivir políticamente evitando esta
persecución grosera en donde nos han
eliminado a los partidos políticos por
los cuales hemos participado el año
pasado tuvimos victorias electorales
fuertes somos el partido más votado y
sin embargo el partido fue eliminado
tuvimos que hacer una alianza con otro
partido político y es a través de esa
que nos estamos expresando con las
listas uno en el caso de argentina bueno
el peronismo es una institución de la
democracia argentina por más intentos de
proscripción en contra de cristina
fernández eso no se logró y el peronismo
bueno pues es una institución fuerte un
partido bastante heterogéneo pero fuerte
y tiene su represente vital
representatividad perdón asegurada en la
democracia argentina sería una era 2 en
alguna oportunidad usted dijo que corría
en riesgo a las elecciones en ecuador
quisiera preguntarle si mantiene esta
postura y de ser así porque considera
esto
el riesgo se mantiene hemos tenido una
advertencia por parte del ministerio de
economía y finanzas al consejo nacional
electoral diciéndole que no hay
suficientes recursos para las elecciones
ahora mismo están enfrascados del
consejo nacional electoral con el
ministerio de finanzas respecto al
presupuesto para las elecciones del
próximo año nosotros nos preocupa que se
quiera utilizar el argumento de falta de
dinero para no realizar las elecciones
así como se han venido haciendo
interpretaciones antojadizas respecto al
marco legal nuestro para evitar nuestra
participación sin embargo yo confío en
que la democracia prevalecerá el sentido
común prevalecerá y no creo que nadie
debe estar jugando con fuego en estas
circunstancias tan difíciles en las que
se encuentra el ecuador ahora si bien
ustedes cuenta por supuesto con una
amplia trayectoria en el escenario de la
política pública en su país porque
considera porque lo han elegido como
candidato a la presidencia nos quizás
hubiesen elegido
digamos más antiguas del correísmo
considera que están buscando alguna
suerte de recambio generacional
absolutamente ese ha sido a un pedido de
la ciudadanía ecuatoriana una renovación
en la política doméstica también ideas
de jóvenes y un pensamiento creativo e
innovador pero sobre todo creo que más
allá de la edad o de las características
de uno está también la necesidad que
tiene la población ecuatoriana de contar
con solvencia en los conocimientos
económicos en la administración pública
los ecuatorianos ahorita no quieren
improvisar quieren definir un gobierno
que pueda plantear soluciones concretas
especialmente en el manejo económico que
ha significado que el 80 por ciento de
las familias ecuatorianas hayan perdido
la mitad o más de sus ingresos mensuales
nosotros tenemos que afrontar el
problema económico junto con la crisis
sanitaria y que nos permita dar
soluciones a las familias ecuatorianas
muy concretas eso lo sabemos hacer
así usted referencia al sector de la
juventud no y hemos podido ver que ha
mantenido muchas reuniones usted con
jóvenes durante todos estos días todas
estas semanas es un sector de la
población más cercano
mismo
mira claro que si tenemos la gran
mayoría de jóvenes en el ecuador que ha
mostrado su simpatía su adhesión a esta
candidatura a ven finalmente una luz de
esperanza de representación también en
una persona joven una nueva forma de
hacer política nosotros hemos planteado
una campaña limpia al resto de los
candidatos eso también ha calado bien
con la juventud e inclusive estamos
planteando una democracia 3.0 qué quiere
decir radicalmente transparente y
totalmente digital creemos que se debe
transparentar por ejemplo los
financiamientos de la campaña que todo
eso se ha publicado con open data en las
páginas web del consejo electoral y que
todos los ciudadanos conozcan en qué se
gasta el dinero de la campaña para así
estar mucho más cerca de la ciudadanía y
mostrar que la democracia si se puede
hacer radicalmente diferente en el siglo
21 para ir finalizando suponiendo un
escenario en el que usted se halla la
presidencia de ecuador cree que la
gobernabilidad del país va a ser difícil
mira nosotros en este caso vamos a
gobernar junto con el pueblo ecuatoriano
por eso no tenemos dudas respecto a la
gobernabilidad estos problemas de
gobernabilidad surgen cuando se gobierna
en contra del pueblo ecuatoriano como lo
hemos visto en los últimos años y ahí se
vuelve ese un verdadero problema que
además conlleva corrupción reparto
política troncha la fea la mala política
que los ecuatorianos ya no queremos
vamos a gobernar junto con el pueblo
ecuatoriano con una base popular social
organizada de abajo hacia arriba y
estamos seguros que mantendremos plena
gobernabilidad con el respaldo de la
mayoría de la población ahora sí para
finalizar no queda menos de un minuto
pero no quiero dejar de preguntarle si
se llegan a realizar las elecciones
creen que serán más que nada anti
correísmo versus correísmo
no esas son categorías que
lamentablemente han sido alimentadas en
el ámbito mediático doméstico a veces
una especie de polarización artificial
que se cree en las redes sociales la
mayoría de los ecuatorianos lo que
quieren en soluciones no peleas entre
políticos y eso es lo que nosotros
venimos a hacer y eso es como estamos
llevando a nuestra campaña y cómo vamos
a llevar nuestro gobierno a nosotros no
nos motiva ni el odio ni la rivalidad
con otros nos motiva el amor a la patria
y eso es lo que vamos a hacer desde el
24 de mayo del 2021
andrés se hará muchísimas gracias por su
presencia la entrevista de france 24 ha
sido un placer
muchísimo gusto santiago un placer
también y a las órdenes muchísimas
gracias a usted a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y por supuesto también en
france24 punto com
[Música]
y